Harry Potter was my introduction to
British men and so I love British men
we're out there and you're a British man
I have a boyfriend but I'm sure we can
work something welcome everybody to
today's most difficult Mary Potter
questions quiz I am your host Mike Rose
I'm a Hufflepuff hi I'm Kelsey and I'm a
Gryffindor hey guys made him Sean and
I'm a Slytherin
hi I'm Carolina and I'm a Ravenclaw I've
never been the type of fan that can like
slay a trivia quiz because people those
Ravenclaw's are out for blood sometimes
I'm not gonna lie and I'm like a
Gryffindor where I'm just like really
enjoy all the memorabilia and going to
the theme parks I pretended that living
hope in Hawaii there was like a Hawaiian
school there and I was like pretending
to go to my own like Hawaiian magic
school I got like a first set of Harry
Potter books from my aunt when I was
like six years old but I only knew
Spanish at the time so I had gotten like
so I read all the series in Spanish
Marina I'm Luna like literally I have
them right here I have moon earrings I
am hurt here's how it works you can
score the maximum of 210 points if you
know the book like the back of your hand
how high can you score let's find out
but try not to let Mikey super
competitive nature has to make friends
were here to win right I'm uh I don't
know
no cheating if shot wins will know why
question number one where in the world
does Ron's brother Bill work France
Romania Egypt or Russia I'm really bad
with names in general and there's ten
Weasley's I don't want any you dripped
in once in Romania because what they
visited Egypt on the family vacation
with Scabbers and and that's how
Scabbers was discovered but then I also
know one of them is in Romania I think
actually I don't think it's Romania I'm
Lizzy Romania in the state all right
audience what do you think make your
selection
oh god my stomach hurts mr. Charlie
in Romania girl isn't Egypt and a mad
Karolina is correct with the Egypt
remember we were talking about the first
book here Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone aka Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone what is the name of
chapter 5 the sorting hat the keeper of
the keys
diagonally or the journey from platform
9 and 3/4 I'm trying to think what the
first five chapters are about you know
how they released like audio like Daniel
Radcliffe like reading the chapters of
Harry Potter I'm like trying to think
about like what he's already said the
only thing that's popping up in my head
is in Chamber of Secrets when Harry's
like diagonally so I'm just gonna go
with Diagon Alley it's either between
diagonally or
I want to say the keeper of the keys but
my heart says diagnolly
I think it's the keeper of the keys I
think the first book is fairly slow oh
looks like going with your heart was the
right way diagonally
one right so I'm really like ecstatic
who does Filch catch after hours once
they three Hagrid's dragon Norbert is it
Harry and Hermione Harry Hermione and
Ron Ron and Hermione or Nevel and Ron I
remember Hermione was a part of the
equation for sure so I know it's not by
just the judgement no LeBron is God I
think it's just two people I don't know
I'm probably just gonna go with Harry
and Hermione just cuz it the first one
I'm gonna go Harry and Hermione as well
oh look at that time for a little bit of
a currency exchange how many nuts equal
one sickle Wow I know it's a big number
it's not five but I don't think it's an
even number because I'm pretty sure most
of them are odd numbers to make it
quirky but like also like why the
imperial system it just doesn't make
sense
exactly it is like that I'm just gonna
go big or go home I'm just gonna guess
29 I think that 25 would divide two
evenly and so in 22 and fives too small
excellent
eliminated and y'all aren't gonna like
this how many chapters are in Sorcerer's
Stone is it 19 18 17 or 16 I know I feel
like it's for sure an odd number because
I'm kind of neurotic so I like to do
things in like in twos I read like two
chapters a days I can finish it in this
amount of time I have some resentment so
I feel like it would be not enough or I
just don't know which one my impulse is
saying 17 was everyone correct
my brain was right and I'm proud of it
way to do too son I decided to be a
rebel and do a different number classic
Slytherin what lesson does Harry look
forward to above all others I know which
one of us is then selection like a you
know fish to water he's like this is
where my legs were born to be that's a
quote from Harry Potter it's an area
where I didn't relate to him because
it's basically like the gym class of
Hogwarts and he's like the jock and he
is good at sports and not so much the
other ones I respect that's not me I'm
not good at the sports I don't think he
was good at sports for a muggle sports
song query you figured it out in which
County this is seriously family reside
so I know it's not Essex because the
Essex is known as the the Jersey Shore
of England I should know this I feel
like this is an easier question but I
know it's not Essex for sure I've
noticed I'm just cuz I go and re
listening oh my god alright
okay that was looking I love all of
Molly Weasley it's like quotes there's
literally a quote that she's just like
you'll boys just drove from Surrey and
back and so that's the only reason why I
know it's cuz they drove to Surrey to
pick up Harry that is an excellent Molly
Weasley impression how many staircases
are Hogwarts JK Rowling I'm gonna go 178
just from that part of me wants to be
like it has to be an odd number because
there
else's odd numbers and Harry Potter's I
want to say 149 I was gonna go with the
odd number one also just cuz like
classic JK Rowling you know what I mean
oh the correct answer is 142 an even
number better luck this next one what
dessert does Dudley at the zoo for his
birthday no i weirdly remember is it ice
cream sundae sticky toffee pudding
banoffee pie or Knickerbocker glory
these are the most British sounding
names ever heard except ice cream sundae
painfully American in this lineup
Karolina which one did you choose
Benassi pie I really thought it was that
remember Dudley like going out his
Knickerbocker glory that's a very berry
recipe on BBC and you know what I'm
doing this week it's next what creature
doesn't leave Jordan bring to Hogwarts a
lizard and owl a tarantula or a rat an
icon I know this Kelsey and Shawn you
look perplexed yeah tarantula feels a
little bit too close to that spider that
Hagrid has you going lizard yeah my
reasoning is the opposite of Kelsey's
I'm going with Treach Allah ready to get
nice and pedantic how many words are in
source paper long can we ask the
audience okay I'm just go both of the
walls
I guessed fully guessed but I got the
right
nicely done sheer dumb luck where are
the prefix compartments located on the
Hogwarts Express is it in the front in
the back in the middle or scattered
about for supervision I have like an
instinct I don't know what it's based
off of but something's telling me to go
for a specific answer I remember
distinctly the moment that Ron and
Hermione
tell Harry they have to go see
in that compartment cuz he kept felt
like feeling excluded about being not a
prefect and then that was just like the
most like decisive moment of like he's
being physically separated from them or
Kelsey you just help me jog my memory
now I know where they stood
oh my gosh that's so cute and
collaborative of you why can't Harry
stay with mrs. fig while the nurses go
to the zoo oh no I kind of what this is
but I'm not gonna say keep helping the
Slytherin oh I see the picture in my
head don't know if it's one of the two
and I could see it in my head right now
the leg was extreme but I knew that she
broke a bone because her cats did
something and she was kind of like madam
confident this is the last question when
someone scores with the Quaffle how many
points does the team earn the options
are five to ten fifteen or twenty points
I distinctly remember having known this
in my youth apparently some knowledge
slipped through the cracks
everybody make a selection I think it
just goes up by tens and I remember like
the numbers felt really fast because of
that Karolina how many points did you
get 112 I try I got a hundred and thirty
eight I got a hundred and fifty five
Kelsey is our winner
her cup goes to Gryffindor we didn't
shoot this time
yeah like Dumbledore didn't have to be
like well you were a good friend I like
to think of myself like Harry you know
Harry wouldn't necessarily know the
exact number of the page that something
happened he lived the story so audience
how well did you do for this how many of
the questions did you get right but will
thank you to all our contestants today
for participating and congratulations to
our winner Gryffindor Kelsey hope to
have you back soon for another Harry
Potter quiz
[Music]